herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich hab heute vor ein paar zuschauer mit
telefonanrufen reinzulegen eigentlich
wollte ich das mit zufälligen nummern
machen aber das war dann so aus
hallo anscheinend nicht so glück
irgendwie habe ich jetzt einfach mal auf
twitter nach ein paar nummern gebeten
die ich anrufen kann
du kannst mir ein paar wörter geschickt
die einbauen sollen die telefonate und
das werde ich jetzt versuchen zu tun
verstand also auf jeden fall challenge
dass ich nicht weggedrückt werden und in
jedem gespräch
drei wörter einbauen muss das komisch
ich bin dabei selbst voll aufgeregt ich
weiß warum aber irgendwie bin ich und
die worte wieder einbauen muss sind
beliebt verkatert atomreaktor ich habe
keine ahnung wie ich das machen soll
aber legen wieder perfekt hier schreibt
einer der kennt ich glaube ich nicht mal
probiert mal aus dann ist unsere
lustiger wenn ich also mit nicht
kenntlich
ihr thema von gestern abend
ich bin noch so krank verkatert wir
gestern war gestern kennengelernt sie
noch zusammen hause fahren ein
kettenglied drauf geflogen
mein kopf war ohne chance wie ein
atomreaktor verkatert bin ich per kopf
her kommt man mit im programm
dafür wird den abend unterwegs
hast du dir heute geschrieben wünscht
ihr viel erfolg
aber ich wohl der falsche nummer merkel
den namen themen abrüstung also ich
hab's geschafft er hat mich nicht
weggeklickt also bin zufrieden ist da
echt auch etwas zu tun aber gut
funktioniert
ok nächsten drei wörter sind klobürste
staubsauger und stecken geblieben also
wie könnte ich das machen vielleicht
redet einfach so drauflos
für die zukunft an mich zu sagen wenn
ich da nicht machen können hallo
[Musik]
hallo jemand da zucker stecken geblieben
challenge geschafft das war nicht sinn
der sache aber komisch ich bin richtig
aufgeregt irgendwie wenn die leute
angeführt die die nächsten wörter sind
steckengeblieben
auch einen bauch scheißen 98 lukas los
mit dir und die user nehmen dafür werbe
ich hab ich überhaupt mich schon
historische überlegt wie ich das
einbauen kann
du bist doch von von wow die obmänner
gegenüber jugenheim dein username ist
doch auf dem bauch scheißen 98
das ding ist mir gerade ingame
steckengeblieben kannst du kurz
online-konten irgendwie keine ahnung
helfen somit weg teleportieren oder so
du bist du wirst auch von wow oder du
bist doch in der obmann um einen versuch
befolgen
ziemlich scheiße das ding ist luca diese
wörter vorgegeben auf den baustart 90
username und steckengeblieben und
probieren wir jetzt irgendwie auch
würdigen selbst zu machen aber auch
jeder beispiel entscheidend ab als
überzeugend genug gute stimme verstellen
[Musik]
nicht wenig wert von gärten und ich
probiere das man elfter vielen dank für
den tipp dann probiert man die nicht nur
als nächste frage luca - shop.de
okay das muss jetzt was machen will
spätestens dann fliegt eigentlich auch
dann könnten sie vielleicht kurz ruhig
sein reicht das okay
guten tag
wenn ich ruf an wegen der bestellung kam
dieses bestellt 3 rudi reichen drei
hunden freistaat können wir gleich
könnte vielleicht ganz kurz ein
ich meine die bestellung auf
lokalnews.de bestell ich nie wieder an
niebel ich komplett zerstört um ein
gutes mittel unangenehm ich wurde noch
nie wer kennt wen stimme hat anscheinend
funktioniert leider was da los ist ich
mich wieder an
okay die nächsten wörter sind rucola
vors gesicht und willst mich hoch nimmt
gesellschaft volk und konfrontationen
sofort für sich trifft mich
hochnäsig denn deine mutter dagegen mit
rucola probieren rucola und nur noch
ersten fall schon gemerkt von ganzem
herzen danke lang unterschied habe er
hat mir dann nummer geschickt ich mache
also ein youtube video wo ich
irgendwelche wörter einbauen muss damit
ich leute mittelhoch nehmen kann
versteht der goldgräber 2 wolf 2 wie die
zahl höher prüfte twitter kannst du noch
mal druck oder sagen wo cola aufgeflogen
nein er kann kräfte hat mein rennen
gemacht und die frage auf wie rucola
sein können ich bin der goldgräber 2
abonniert seiner mitbürger cola könnt
ihr das bitte deine mutter die
verwaltung bekomme ich probier's mal ein
zwei nummern aus
suchen wir noch drei wörter aus schmand
mineralien und fruchtig hoffe einfach
nur dass ich nicht irgendwie in kleinen
kindern ab und wird nicht von fetisch
erzählen wollen wir noch ihre eltern
fragt was das ist aber wir probieren
[Musik]
verfahren tag bist du wie aus dem
fetisch forum von fünf tätig
unterkirnach bist du die aus dem bett zu
schmand und mir radien auf meine füße
tut mir leid ich bin der goldgräber 2
auf youtube
ich vermisse die rindfleisch ist ihre
überwachungsaufgaben übertragungs
gesetzt
ringgleich etikettier und
überwachungsaufgaben übertragungsgewinn
frau und der golfkrieg von der
goldgräber schwermann in der wolke was
zwar in der goldgräber
wie kommst du wieder erkennen obwohl ich
meine sprache versteht hat die kranken
[Musik]
mit jemanden grüßen der kämpfe ein
okay okay
jonas schönrock geführt ob es hat euch
gefallen und wir sind zwar nicht mein
ziel